bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine golf
c'est désormais officiel des
investisseurs chinois vont injecter de
l'argent dans l'open de france de golf
cette mesure permettra d'augmenter la
dotation est d'attirer les meilleurs
joueurs européens dès cet été nous y
reviendrons dans un instant handball il
n'y a pas eu de miracle pour l'équipe
senior masculine de montigny bretonnants
coupe de france régionale lésigny
montain se sont inclinés à domicile
contre voici le résumé dans quelques
minutes
taekwondo la ville de trappes accueilli
ce week-end et championnat ile de france
de la discipline au gymnase paul mallet
l'épreuve majeure dans la course à la
qualification pour les championnats de
france au total 300 sportifs ont
participé à l'événement on prend
maintenant la direction des greens pour
parler de l'open de france de golf
l'officialisation était attendue depuis
plusieurs semaines elle est au top
elle est intervenue ce lundi 9 janvier
au ministère des affaires étrangères à
paris
l'open de france organisé tous les ans
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines va devenir en 2010 est l'un des
plus grands tournois repeint en
intégrant le rolex series regroupant les
tournois les plus prestigieux
le consortium chinois à chan a décidé
d'investir dans les rendez-vous évinois
pour les cinq prochaines années la
dotation va être triplés elle va
atteindre un peu plus de 6 6 millions
d'euros conséquence les meilleurs
joueurs du circuit européen devrait
participer aux prochaines éditions le
français alexander levy a déjà lancé sa
venue cet après midi notre journaliste
nicolas quere lovitz a pu recueillir la
réaction du président de la ffg agents
chao au niveau des tournois européens se
met à nouveau plutôt en phare en lumière
et ça donne du coup un éclairage nouveau
et j'espère que non seulement les
français seront sensibles à cette
nouveauté mais également tous les
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
profiteront à 2 qe2 d'un événement
maintenant un plus fort 13h09 mondial du
handball à présent un match de gala
était organisé ce week end à montigny le
bretonneux l'équipe senior masculine de
la smb recevait le club de roissy en 32e
de finale de la coupe de france
régionale
après un début un bon début de match
lésigny mon teint qui évolué à deux
divisions en dessous de leurs
adversaires du jour se sont finalement
inclinés 33 à 25
retour sur son match à match à remontage
signé exhalant laventure de
montigny-le-bretonneux en coupe de
france régionale s'arrête au stade des
32e de finale les signé mon teint qui
évolue en division leur se sont inclinés
contre voici
l'équipe de prénationale deux divisions
au dessus de la smb après un premier
quart d'heure convaincant où les vert et
noir ont fait jeu égal avec leurs
homologues dont il n'y a craqué dans les
dix dernières minutes de la première
période il n'a jamais pu combler son
retard de cul suite score final 33 à 25
en effet on a perdu mais je suis assez
satisfait de l'équipe parce que nos
récits à tenir une équipe qui évolue en
prénationale pendant 15 minutes qu'on a
fait jeu égal pendant 15 minutes après
ça s'est joué sur des détails techniques
essentiellement la finition pour
commencer on a eu pas mal d'échecs au
shoot une défense un petit peu un petit
peu trop laxiste aussi on a on a
beaucoup trop attendu à 6 mètres et ça
nous a coûté cher
malgré cette défaite
montigny-le-bretonneux aura réussi un
parcours historique dans la compétition
les joueurs ont réussi à éliminer deux
équipes de prénationale pour se hisser
en trop deuxièmes de finale une première
pour le club
on est allé en normandie cette année
c'est la première fois qu'on sort de la
région parisienne c'est sympa ça fait
toujours plaisir
après oui c'est la première fois qu'on
arrive aussi loin j'espère qu'on fera la
même chose au moins aussi bien
prochain objectif pour montigny le
bretonneux se reconcentrer sur le
championnat de division honneur qu'on
espérait monter cette année les montants
sont actuellement la première place du
classement avec seulement deux défaites
depuis le début de la saison
direction maintenant les pelouses de
football en promotion d'honneur trap a
été tenu en échec ce week-end sur le
terrain de puteaux en match en retard de
la poule c de ph
le score est resté nul et vierge en sept
parties à zéro à zéro classement les
trappistes sont toujours dans le ventre
mou à la 6e place avec un bilan de 4
victoires 4 nuls et 2 défaites depuis le
début du championnat on reste à trappes
pour parler de taekwondo la ville a
accueilli ce week-end et championnat il
dit ile de france de la discipline au
gymnase paul mallet une épreuve majeure
dans la course à la qualification pour
les championnats de france présentation
de la compétition à montage de sandrine
fontaine
le taekwondo sport de combat d'origine
sud-coréenne était à l'honneur ce
week-end à trappes 300 sportifs ont
participé au championnat ile-de-france
seigneur et à la coupe de france
vétérans gymnase paul mallet une
habitude pour le club local
on a eu l'occasion de faire
quatre compétitions déjà la première ça
a été un dépannage et
je pense que voilà l'accueil le
professionnalisme aussi d argent de la
ville de trappes
tout ça fait que aujourd'hui on
accueille encore cidf au sein du gymnase
la compétition deuxième étape
qualificative pour les championnats de
france a attiré des têtes d affiche de
la discipline dans la catégorie des plus
de 87 kg signé m bow membre de l'équipe
de france depuis 2007 et anciens
coéquipiers de pascal gentil aux jo de
pékin en 2008 s'est inscrit pour cet
événement c'est la complète il faut
faire pour faire les championnats de
france donc c'est les qualificatifs en
fait les championnats régional pour se
qualifier aux championnats france encore
sur obligé de les faire donc c'est pour
ça
des sportifs renommés mais également des
stars en devenir ont combattu ce
week-end pour les détecter et suivre
leur évolution des recruteurs ont fait
le déplacement
on peut éventuellement recruter ou
sélectionner des partenaires
d'entraînement pour les équipes
nationales en préparation sur des
objectifs majeurs comme les championnats
du monde chanteur de rock ou
éventuellement le jeux olympiques
le club de trappes accueillerait
également l'open labellisé ile de france
les 18 et 19 février une autre étape
qualificative pour les championnats de
france des tatamis on passe à la 8e
édition du vendée globe après un peu
plus de 60 jours en mer les deux
skippers évinois louis burton originaire
de rambouillet le versailles et éric
bellion sont toujours en course pour ce
tour du monde en solitaire et sans
escale le premier est actuellement large
du brésil et remonte sur le 6e jean le
cam
de son côté éric bellion n'a pas encore
franchi le cap horn mais reste à la
neuvième position de cette course les
deux navigateurs évinois devrait rentrer
aux sables d'olonne d'ici la fin février
en cyclisme c'est désormais une
tradition dans les yvelines la course
paris-nice s'élancera pour la septième
année consécutive du département cette
année bois d'arcy rochefort en yvelines
ont été désignés village départ par les
organisateurs
les images sont signés à patrick jacques
de dixmude les ivy nous en ont désormais
l'habitude pour la septième année
consécutive le département va cueillir
en mars la course cycliste paris nice
l'annoncé officielle a été faite ce
mardi 3 janvier à versailles devant plus
d'une cinquantaine de journalistes
je crois que c'est d'abord un plaisir
pour les yvelinois sais pas pour vous
qu'on fait ça naturellement j'ai une
façon de faire parler des yvelines
c'est valorisant pour notre département
après mon repas en 2015 et conflans
sainte honorine en 2016 c'est l'avis de
bois d'arcy qui a été retenue pour
ouvrir le bal sur cette course du soleil
de 5 mars prochain cette année pas de
prologue mais une étape de 148
kilomètres dans la vallée de chevreuse
il fallait mettre un petit peu la
lumière sur sur la vallée heureuse avait
quelque chose à faire sur la vallée de
chevreuse en sortant de bollards si on
pouvait faire quelque chose de
sympathique pour tous les gens qui qui
font du vélo le dimanche en région
parisienne et j'en fais partie de faire
du vélo et chevreux et mes séjours
sympathique
et elle a une histoire cette vallée donc
bah c'était aussi une façon de mettre un
coup de projecteur sur sur cette vallée
une étape qui devrait se disputer au
sprint dans les derniers mètres entre
les 22 équipes inscrites
la logique voudrait en effet cocoben
mars mari djata il y est à nouveau un
sprint c'est l'une des quatre étapes de
paris-nice dévolue aux sprinteurs dans
la logique voudrait en effet que se sont
inscrits heures avec un très gros
plateau de sprinteurs cette année les
meilleurs du monde quittait ipod
christophe norvégiens et les français
démarrent y voyait le 6 mars les
cyclistes du paris-nice passeront
également par rochefort en yvelines une
commune de 900 habitants avant de
quitter le département au niveau de
saint-arnoult on continue à parler
cyclisme c'est un exploit inédit qui
s'est déroulé sur la piste du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines ce
mercredi 4 janvier
robert marchand 105 ans de guerre
mondiale et cesse président à son actif
a réussi un nouveau record de l'or dans
l'enceinte évinoise leucémie le senior a
réalisé à plus de 1000 spectre de vent
plus de 1000 spectateurs et 100
journalistes vingt deux kilomètres 547
nous l'avons interrogé avec patrick
jacques de dixmude le reportage
il a repoussé les limites de son sport
robert marchand 150 de guerre mondiale
et cesse président à son actif a établi
un nouveau record de l'heure dans une
catégorie d'âge créé spécialement pour
lui le centenaire a réalisé ce mercredi
4 janvier 22 km 547 m une performance
inédite pour le soutenir tout au long de
son défi une centaine de supporteurs de
son club de l'ardéchoise a fait le
déplacement
700 kilomètres en allemand parti le
matin 6h30
on a passé une journée formidable lanka
c'est notre mascotte au sein de
l'ardéchoise notre mascotte son père
marchand c'est robert marchand du père
marchand c'est robert mans au total plus
de 80 journalistes et 1000 spectateurs
ont garni les tribunes du vélodrome
parmi eux marcel le quéré spécialistes
de la discipline qui pourrait s'attaquer
au record de robert marchand dans
quelques années j'ai encore 35 ans à
tenir pour arriver à son niveau c'est
exceptionnel ce qui fait déjà nous à 70
ans c'est déjà très difficile
à ton âge et merveilleux ça nous laisse
de l'espoir de tenir encore plusieurs
années
une journée parfaite pour robert
marchand mais le centenaire qui a tourné
à 35 secondes au tour à la fin de son
expo ne se satisfait pas pleinement de
sa performance
j'ai pas vu les minutes
une simple erreur de jeunesse robert
marchand pourrait tenter de corriger ce
détail à l'occasion d'un nouveau record
dans deux ans apparemment il lui en
reste sous la
encore un grand bravo à robert marchand
pour son record une performance qui
pourrait lui valoir d'être décoré de la
légion d'honneur dans les prochains mois
on passe maintenant à l'agenda du
week-end
on commence cet agenda part du rugby
après un mois de trêve c'est la reprise
en division honneur l'équipe seniors du
rugby club de versailles reçoit manque
lit mais pour le premier match de la
phase retour
un gros morceau puisque les joueurs du
nord du département occupe actuellement
la 2e place et versailles auront
certainement à coeur de faire tomber
l'un des favoris de la poule chez eux à
domicile
si vous voulez assister à la rencontre
le match programmé ce dimanche à 15
heures toujours en rugby mais cette fois
ci en échelon en dessous en promotion
d'honneur le sky rugby reprend également
le championnat ce week-end avec la
réception de noisy le sec
un choc des extrêmes entre le sky qui
occupe la tête du classement et noisy
lanterne rouge de la poule
le match est programmé ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade du bout des clos à
maurepas
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]